hi I'm Dale this is making with ml and
today I want to talk about something
you've probably experienced if you've
ever been on the internet I'm talking
about user-generated content that
violates a platform's Terms of Service
[Music]
almost all content platforms whether
they're u2 or Twitter or OkCupid or the
New York Times have some strategy for
dealing with bad user input and this is
called their moderation strategy you can
imagine what's okay to post on Reddit or
a dating app might not fly in the New
York Times so these platforms have to
consider what is allowed under their
Terms of Service
these platform and haters also have to
consider the implementation of their
moderation strategy let me give you some
options option number one you could hire
a team of human moderators to go through
every piece of user-submitted content
before it's posted to okay it this is
called pre moderation and as you can
imagine it's really good at making sure
that nothing's bad slips through the
cracks because human beings are actually
looking at what's being posted but it
also doesn't scale very well and it
takes a large human moderation team that
scales with the size of your user input
so you'd only use it if it's extremely
extremely important that no bad bits get
through the cracks option number two you
could ask your users to flag bad content
for you and then send this flag content
to a human moderation team for later of
you maybe in a sort of priority queue
where they figure out what's important
to review first this is called post
moderation because the content is
moderated after it's already been posted
for example when you're served a YouTube
video or a Google Ad and you have the
option to report that content you're
seeing a post moderation strategy the
advantage to doing this is that it
allows your human moderation team to
scale but the disadvantage of course is
that then your users have to actually
see this potentially offensive content
and in some instances this would be
unacceptable both of these approaches
have major drawbacks you're either
having your cue and moderation team go
through every single piece of content
before it's posted or you're potentially
subjecting your users to content that
should have been flagged but that wasn't
and neither of these approaches work for
real-time moderation like for example if
we're doing a video stream or add
messages which brings us to option
number three a I powered moderation
which is what we're building today the
idea is to use machine learning to
analyze Khan
like text speech images video and flag
the content the instant that it's
created you can then send that content
to a team of human moderators so that
your users never have to see it but your
moderation team can scale better now you
might wonder why not use a I should just
moderate your entire moderation solution
so let me add a disclaimer here the
sheet learning models are always
probabilistic which means that they
invariably make mistakes and sometimes
they're biased meaning that they make
mistakes in particularly bad consistent
and potentially embarrassing ways so I
always recommend using AI in conjunction
with human beings having this human in
the loop for example you might have your
algorithms put comments into a
moderation queue for your moderators to
review or allow users to repeal
decisions that were made by the AI so
knowing that today I'll show you how to
make a simple AI powered moderation bot
for the chat platform discord let's get
started today we're gonna build a bot
that sits in a discord server and
analyzes user messages when the bot
detects a message is toxic it will fly
it with a dynamite emoji it'll also keep
track of insulting flirtatious spammy
and nonsensical messages and flag them
with appropriate emoji
it'll keep a scoreboard of emojis or
Karma for each user in the chat room and
if a user types too many toxic messages
they'll get kicked from the room now
don't worry if you've never done any
machine learning before because this
project we're gonna use the perspective
API to do the complicated machine
learning bits for us it takes in strings
of text and produces scores for
different attributes like toxicity
insulting this explicitness and even
just a coherence to create these models
the prospective team use millions of
comments from data sources like the New
York Times Wikipedia and many other open
datasets if you want to see how they
built the model and architecture behind
it and even learn how to train your own
check out the perspective API website to
use perspective you need to fill out a
quick google form explaining how you
plan to use the api once your project is
approved you should be able to use it in
your app next go ahead and download the
making with ml github repo and navigate
to the discord moderator folder here's
all the code you'll need to run your bot
the file prospective Jas shows you how
to use the perspective API in JavaScript
at the top you can see all the different
types of attributes the tool recognizes
like insult toxicity
spam incoherence partition and more now
let's connect the respective API to a
discord bot to do that you'll need to
sign up for a discord developer account
once you have an account create a new
application then create a new bot by
clicking on bot in the left-hand panel
give your bought an avatar and a cute
name and you're set the brain of our
discord bot lives entirely in the file
discord is here at the top you can see
our emoji map which tells our bot how to
react to different user comments
rotations get a kissy face and spam gets
a fish down in the evaluate message
function we call the perspective analyze
text function to detect attributes in
the message if an attribute is found we
react with an emoji and if the user is
sent too many toxic messages we
temporarily kick them from the channel
the next step is to run your discord bot
from the command line awesome now it's
ready to be added to your server in the
discord developer panel under OAuth
select the permission your bot needs
sending messages adding reactions and
kicking users copy the URL above into
your browser and from here you'll be
able to add your bot to a server now if
we can wear a discord server boom the
moderator bot is in the channel keeping
track of everything I type and reacting
with emojis if you want to build this
discord moderator by yourself the code
github and you can follow along in my
very detailed blog post in the
description and there you go now you
have your very own AI powered chat bot
moderator for discord now the moderation
strategy that our bot used is very
simple it just kicks users from the
channel when they say too many things
the AI thinks is toxic but like we
discussed earlier that's actually not a
very good strategy for a real in
production moderation because the model
can make mistakes in fact the respective
website specifically says this API is
not designed for fully automated
moderation solutions and they even list
a bunch of known biases that the model
has just think of it this way
ai is just one piece of the puzzle and
it works better when human partners are
in the loop that's all for now if you
want to learn more about moderation in
AI and make sure you check out the blog
below and let me know what problems you
want to see soft with AI in the comments
below but remember those comments are
moderated too that's all for now see you
next time
[Music]
you
you